- Can I let you guys
in on a little secret?
I really want our show to be a safe space.
A place where we can leave
our differences at the door
and just feel welcomed.
This is an all ages party
and everyone's invited.
Our dream with this show
is to find common ground,
or as I call it,
the pretty little middle,
#prettylittlemiddle.
And no matter what your
beliefs or values are today,
I wanted to celebrate Ruth Bader Ginsburg.
And I found all these things
as I dove in this weekend,
I read everything.
I read her book.
I watched her documentary.
I immersed myself in her life.
Her marriage was just so amazing,
the way her and her husband
supported each other.
When he was sick,
she took care of him and did his homework.
When she was sick,
he took care of her.
They were so supportive of each other,
and she just had this incredible strategy
about the long game and
she had this ability to be
confident and comfortable
in silence as she talks about in her book.
I learned something, I'm horrible at that.
Her attitude about anger,
pushing people away,
that I learned from too, you know?
She was a law student
and a judge and a lawyer
and she has this incredible legacy.
And now she inspires a
whole new generation.
And, I kind of thought after
being able to ace any test
you could give me on RBG,
what can I talk about on the
show about her, you know?
We're all seeing
everything all weekend and
I was compelled to talk about
how she found common ground
with all her colleagues
on the Supreme Court,
especially when they didn't agree.
And they didn't argue small fights.
It wasn't like, "Did you
see the game last night?"
Or "I swear to God,
if you park your car
near my driveway again"
or "What's better, the
French fry or tater tot?"
Like, they are confronting
the biggest issues.
And things are all easy when we agree.
But when we don't, can we find the way in
where we might come together?
I know I am naive in thinking this, but
she was able to maintain friendships
with colleagues who she disagreed with.
And it just moved me so much.
And I thought, you know what?
I wanna shine the light on this.
And I found the lyrics to this opera.
They were written for
her and Antonin Scalia.
And they were like on opposite
sides of the spectrum.
And they still found a way to
have an incredible friendship.
And when I read the words to this,
I had an incredible revelation.
That even though they
felt like they represented
the divides and attitudes and values,
they could still work together.
And it gave me so much hope.
(upbeat music)